what is going on what is going on
michael is um sick and he wants one of
us to rescue i'm not sure
i'm coming michael oh i'm gonna save you
i don't know okay hold on michael i am
coming
how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything mcu and today we have a
really cool
detail revealed about the wanda vision
series from none other than
marvel studios as president kevin feige
himself
now everybody's already super excited
for the wanna vision series but i think
a lot of people are going to get even
more excited after you hear this news
especially if you are a fan of the
office or
parks and rec in a recent interview with
entertainment weekly magazine they
talked to marvel studios president kevin
feige where he revealed a lot about the
upcoming one of vision series that i'll
cover over the next few days so be sure
to subscribe and hit the notification
bell so you don't miss out on any videos
and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a zombie
hulk funko pop provided by
heroeshideout.com
so of course in this interview by
entertainment weekly they are trying to
get as much from the cast and the crew
that they can possibly get especially
when you have such a
already pretty crazy show and one thing
that kevin feige did address
is how the world around wanda envisioned
how their reality changes from different
sitcoms to different sitcoms
he reveals that wanda envisions world
the sitcom world that they live in
shifts as they go through the decades
and the decades change
now this isn't really that surprising
this has actually been rumored before
but now it's just confirmed by marvel
studios as president we know that by the
time the one division series ends we'll
have seen
wiccan and speed wanda envisions twin
boys go from infants to teenagers
and then hopefully they'll go on to set
up the young avengers but here's where
things get
very interesting and very exciting when
talking about the different sitcoms and
the different decades
kevin feige said this we go up to the
modern family and the office
style the talk to the camera shaky
camera
documentary style so what he's saying
here is that eventually one of the
realities that they live in
one of these tv sitcom realities is
going to be like the office and is going
to be like parks and rec
and this is just an absolutely brilliant
move by kevin feige and marvel studios
because they know how big the office is
and they know how big parks and rec is
ready i was born ready
i'm ron swanson
they know what type of following these
shows have and they know that it's going
to get people to
want to watch the one division series
more than we already do so far
this means that they're planning on the
series being pretty comedic
now we expected some humor but i wasn't
expecting things like wanda casually
looking into the camera or the same for
vision
in a show about witches and witchcraft
and fake realities
it's nice to know that they truly are
focusing on the comedic
aspect of it as well exposing yourself
to germs
is the best way to make yourself
stronger so by that rationality if i had
to sneeze i should just sneeze on you
yes i would welcome it and truly if
you're going to top things off with a
decade because we know eventually it
will stop and she'll discover that their
reality isn't exactly real
but if you're going to stop in a certain
decade the modern family the office the
parks and rec decade is a great one to
stop at
because it's the one that we live in and
it's the one that pop culture at least
knows the most because even if you've
never seen the office or you've never
seen parks and rec
you've definitely seen clips or memes or
something from these two series
and also if you haven't seen them i
highly recommend them they are hilarious
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
say com what's the procedure everyone
what's the procedure
and hopefully some of that hilariousness
is going to be brought into the one
division series
so this is super super exciting but be
on the lookout for my video tomorrow as
i'll be covering more about this
entertainment weekly interview and i
have a big video
one that involves the mutants and the
x-men so be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos be sure
to like the video if you enjoyed it and
let me know what you're looking forward
to the most about them going up to the
office style decade
let me know in the comments down below
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof